Oh,
coffee on a Tuesday in 19
the pole j Getty Museum in Los Angeles
is beautiful,
not only for the breathtaking artifacts
and it's large collection,
but for the palatial architecture and
for the experience of going there to the
top of that mountain and a trolley car
above the city from some of its
balconies.
You can see the entirety of greater Los
Angeles sat beneath its film,
move,
smug,
and you can see the ocean and the West.
It's gardens or tranquil.
You can sit on the grass and enjoy the
day and then it's back down the trolley
and you feel educated,
cultured better for the experience.
The next morning over coffee and you
read in the paper that archeological
sites in Iraq have been ravaged by
looters who have sunk holes into the
dirt and rip thousands of year old
artifacts from the ground to sell them
on the market for cat still fresh from
your trip to the getty.
Your newfound sense of culture is
outraged by such disregard for history
and you begin to think of those
artifacts you saw yesterday in the
museum as the luckiest orphans in the
world.
Thank God for museums.
You say,
thank God for the getty.
Here's the essential problem of the
antiquities market.
On the one side you have leaders who
everybody hates,
and on the other side you have museums
which everybody loves.
It's hard to see at first glance that
these two things are unavoidably
connected.
See looters,
Luke,
because there's money in it.
These are poor people and they need to
feed their families.
Okay,
so let's say that it circulates around
the village,
that there is a man entailed,
willing to pay good money for Sumerian
cylinder,
seals from the Babylonian era,
and the guy next door knows exactly
where to find them.
Well,
our would be luder travels with his
neighbor in the middle of the night to
the chosen archaeological site and sinks
holes into the ground looking for
Sumerian cylinder seals.
He doesn't find anything for awhile.
Eventually he comes upon a pocket of
them.
Now his shovel has smashed five beyond
all recognition,
but two are still intact even in good
condition,
and this will feed his family for a
month.
So he goes to town and seeks the buyer
out.
Now he pays a little bit less than was
reported,
but beggars can't be choosers and this
is his first time.
Now the buyer is excited because these
cylinder seals are very hot right now
among private collectors and he expects
a good turnover from here.
The cylinder seals run a complicated
route of buyers and sellers and
smugglers and dealers across oceans and
international borders.
Maybe staying awhile in the Geneva
freeport where storage items are exempt
from customs regulations,
you know,
just to keep a low profile.
It's an almost impossible route to
follow.
An antiquities dealers are very good at
confusing the authorities who mostly
stay five steps behind and out of
jurisdiction.
Eventually,
those very,
very old Sumerian cylinder seals will
end up in one of two places.
Private collections or museum.
Why?
Well,
because like I said,
those seals are very hot right now and
in an estimated $4,000,000,000
a year.
Industry hot is really.
Yes,
the dealer is fooled the authorities,
but it's small potatoes.
When you consider how much they fooled
us,
see the whole thing can be boiled down
to a simple business model.
Supply and demand without demand.
There is no supply and so museums like
the getty in Los Angeles where the met
in New York City or the MFA in Boston
can go on demanding elicit artifacts
because most people don't realize that
this causes this.
It's why when people like Philippe de
Montebello,
the former director of the met say
things like,
we're lucky,
allergist abandoned the shivering orphan
child on a cold,
rainy day in the street.
Defense,
defensive their practices,
we can call a big bullshit.
These people are the parents orphaning
their children off the metaphor.
It isn't really.
It was Montebello in 2006 who had to
return the fame Euphronios Krater to
Italy after it was shown to have had
been clearly alluded from a tomb and
secretary.
He later said,
how much more could you learn from
knowing which particular hole that came
out of?
Well,
this just shows you how ignorant these
people really are.
As the answer to his question is,
of course,
virtually every.
There's an archeological term called
provenience.
It means the location of an object in
three dimensional space in relation to
all the things around it.
Another word would be context and
objects for tells us 99 percent of the
information about its significance and
use.
It's why archeologists use all those
little tools to dig things up to
preserve the provenience.
Okay,
so an example.
If a Roman coin was found by a
snorkelers off the coast of Alexandria
and sold to museum,
the experts there could probably tell
you a lot about what year it was made
and what meant it came from even in.
That's a nice amount of superficial
information.
Let's say the circle or didn't touch the
coin and instead reported the fine will
archeologists searching the area,
then find many more coins and not only
can they tell you about the year that it
was made in the mint that it came from,
but they can start to tell you a new
story about the shipping trade in the
Roman era.
Mediterranean Sea context is everything.
The aim of archeology is to tell the
most true,
most comprehensive story about the past,
under the assumption that both the past
and the truth are worth something to.
In 2007,
the getty returned 40 artifacts to Italy
under mounting pressure from
international authorities.
Now they did it quietly and without
admitting wrongdoing,
but these repatriations are becoming
more to stop the supply.
You have to choke the demand and to do
that you have to educate people about
how the antiquities market really works.
You have to show them how they are being
fooled by palatial architecture and
great presentation.
You have to say to them that though
these places are undeniably beautiful,
sitting as they do on the top of
mountains above the city,
that there are cultures being destroyed
and forgotten every day and they had
their own ideas about architecture and
presentation in beauty.
Don't you think that their ideas in our
culture has a right to be remembered
correctly?
High nerd writer here,
this is my friend Sam.
He just finished making a World War II
short,
epic called the American starring made.
You want to check it out and I suggest
that you do it because it is pretty
fucking awesome.
You can find that link in the doodly.
Do anything to add Sam.